- He's an American
hip-hop recording artist
from Detroit, Michigan.
- He signed with Good Music
in 2007, Def Jam in 2008,
and Rock Nation in 2014.
- His album Dark Sky Paradise
earned him his first #1
on the Billboard 200.
- He's Big Sean and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
- One thing people need is inspiration.
They need a lot of things,
but they definitely need that too.
Inspiration can, you know,
it can create anything.
Inspiration can create the best ideas.
It can create the million dollar ideas.
It can create the billion dollar ideas.
It can create leaders,
inspiration can change everything.
So I feel like people need that.
Man, you just got to
stay real to yourself,
not ever try to follow the trends.
That's when you get
lost in the sauce, man.
You got to do what you feel, man,
be creative and don't
be scared to be yourself
and always keep that faith.
I've been in the darkest times in my life
when I didn't know what
was going to happen,
and I was flat broke.
Anything you can think of,
man, I done been through it.
And you got to be strong
enough to make it through.
It just makes it that much sweeter
when everything starts going right.
When I was in the third grade
and my teacher was like,
now this is some funny shit though,
my teacher was asking
people what the want to be
and they was like lawyers, doctors, this,
and I was like, "I want to be
a rapper signed to Def Jam."
I said that in the third grade.
And my teacher was like (groans).
And she was like, "Oh no" and shit.
Same teacher wants me to come
back to speak at my school.
- [Man In Crowd] Don't do that shit, cuz!
(crowd shouting)
- No, no, no, that's not my point!
My point is, whatever you're doing,
you make sure you follow your heart
and do what the (bleep) you
want to do, that (bleep).
You don't want to be 50 or 60 years old
wishing you would've, could've,
should've did something.
That's the best advice I could give you.
And I promise you if you follow your heart
and always keep that faith,
it'll lead you to your pot of gold,
it'll lead you to your million dollars,
whatever you want in life,
it'll lead you to that.
I promise, man.
I learn something different
from everybody, it all depends.
From Ye, I just learned,
you know, always follow
your heart, always be real,
straight up, don't take no (bleep),
you know what I'm saying.
Common is somebody who, like,
no matter what Common has
going on with one thing,
he'll always have something else going on.
He'll always be like, if
he's not acting right then,
he's making music, if
he's not making music,
he's always finding some
ways to brand himself away
from music too, and I respect that.
You know what I'm saying?
He's more than just a rapper,
he's an all around business man
and I respect that about Common.
You know, it's those
little things you learn
from guys like that that you hang around,
that you take little tips
and apply to yourself.
Risk.
There is no chance to evolve
and progress without taking risk.
I feel like it's the necessary
element to self development.
It's the key to living
life to the fullest.
Risk, according to Webster, is the chance
of injury, damage, loss, the
failure of your expectations.
But I realize that it's also
the opportunity to learn
and gain the fulfillment
of your desires and dreams.
When I think of risk or
just what risk means,
I feel like I might think of being afraid,
or really risk is a way
to overcome what you fear.
You can be afraid to risk
something or everything
because you don't want
to lose what you have.
Because you're afraid you may fail
or think you can't handle
it, or whatever the case.
You'll spend so much energy and time
trying to keep what you
have instead of progressing
into something new.
Everything changes, nothing
stays the same forever.
Nothing.
From business to personal,
everything in between.
I realize that you can't be afraid.
A lot of us aren't all the way satisfied,
but are scared to lose
security and what we do have.
I might not be able to get a better job,
or a better partner, et cetera.
Or even as bad as prison is, you know,
there are people who don't want to leave
because they're afraid
of what's on the outside,
or being able to succeed.
The number one thing I got
to remind myself sometimes,
and remember,
is that life is here not to
survive, but to live it up,
to expand, to grow.
When you settle for
what's familiar, or safe,
it's because we forget
that God is our security.
God is creating all this.
And that's the only security.
You can try and find
security in people, in jobs,
or in anything man-made,
but there's no point
because everything is designed
to change, including you.
We want our songs like
memories, desire, want,
and needs (bleep), you can keep quiet.
Most people who have successfully
taken risks and succeeded,
have failed too.
But the point is you
learn from every lesson,
you learn from every risk.
Change is always exciting.
It's always exciting when
you know God is involved.
The world is designed for change.
Don't ever be afraid to take risks.
- How did you make this perseverance
to push through all of this?
- I don't know man, I just did.
People, man, my grandma is one
of the biggest inspirations.
My mom, you know.
My desire to want to give
everybody around me a better life.
The desire to want to
live a better life, man,
that's my whole motivation
coming from Detroit City.
People don't make it out of
the west side of Detroit.
I believe is just spreading that love,
you know what I'm saying, that good vibes.
I live like a hippy, you
know what I'm saying,
so I believe in just feeling great.
Letting people know how I
made it happen for myself,
and making it happen.
One thing I used to be a victim
of, when I was in the studio
with Kanye, Jay-Z, all these people,
and they would do verse to a song,
I would try to do a verse like they would,
you know what I'm saying,
and that just wasn't me.
It wasn't me, it didn't sound right.
So I just realized that you
have to stay in your own lane,
you have to do what you do,
and go all the way with it.
Don't look back.
My definition of success,
I think success is more
of an emotion than it is
what you get physically.
Success isn't how much money you make.
It isn't, like...
It's just about what you accomplish,
how you feel at the end of it all,
you know, that's success.
I feel like I've been
successful in some ways,
but I'm still hungry for
that success that I want,
and I'm going to get it.
I'm going to make it happen.
I'm young now, 25, you know,
and I look at people who,
who I consider successful,
and they're way older,
and I got a lot of time to get it right.
I'm learning, so I think
success is definitely an emotion
more than 100 million
dollars, or anything.
- Yeah, I've interviewed
quite a lot of people,
and I ask that same question,
and that's one of the best answers.
- Really?
- Yeah, really, man.
- Yeah, success is like...
Yeah, you can be successful,
there's people that are the
richest people in the world...
You can be the richest person in the world
and not be successful.
People who have the most money
got the most problems, too,
and are the unhappiest.
There's people who are
taking the bus everyday
and got a family, and
they're the happiest ever.
You know, so I think
success isn't measured
by how much money you make
or the house you want, it's
measured by how you feel.
Imagination.
How many people you know, I
mean for real know, made it?
Got on.
Nobody from my city.
Detroit, hell no.
I ain't no Eminem.
I don't know nobody who did.
These waves are for real too.
I know I made it my point
to be the one who made it.
The one people knew before I made it,
to show everybody it was real.
I grew up watching Biggie, Mase,
I wanted a Rolly like Pop, you feeling me?
I wanted a money like Master P.
Stunting like the big timers.
I wanted to pop champagne, you feel me?
(chuckles)
I wanted to put my crew on,
have a label like Rockefeller,
put the city on.
You know.
I started off young, spitting, rapping,
trying to be a role model,
trying to be signed.
I knew I was going to make
it, I just ain't know how.
But I knew.
(girls screaming)
- Killed it today!
(girls mumble)
- My mom taught me early on,
this world is what you make it,
you create your own environment.
It all starts with a vision.
What you can imagine, you can create.
I came up middle class.
Family!
- Family!
- Not really having shit to spare,
not having no money to spare.
Had to work for new clothes, gas money.
I always wanted to get
my mom what she wanted,
you know, cars, Benz, houses, whatever.
I ain't have it, but I
can see it in my head.
I could feel the energy of it.
Built a house upon that
ass, that's an ass-state.
Roll my weed on it, that's an ass-tray.
Say, Ye, say, Ye, don't
we do this every day, day
(mumbles) like we just have payday.
I don't even know if that makes sense,
but it always made sense to me.
It was all real to me.
My imagination was real to me.
The people that used to tell
me I was wasting my time
or said it wouldn't work out,
or the people who ain't have (bleep),
they ain't have nothing.
It wasn't until after meeting
the people I grew up to,
getting a chance to meet
my idols, work with them,
I realize they believe what I believe.
Imagining it.
Changing the world, changing their world.
A lot of people could imagine,
but wouldn't believe it,
couldn't fathom it.
Not me.
I believe.
(fireworks exploding)
I had imagination.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
- We made this video because
Patrick Vane asked us to.
Now if you have a famous
entrepreneur you'd like Evan
to make a video of, leave
it in the comments below
and we will make him do it.
- I'd also love to know which
of Big Sean's Top 10 Rules
meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments below,
and we're going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.